my man over in El Salvador naib ukele
the president of El Salvador has another
great propaganda video out we played
earlier this week a propaganda video
from the El Salvadoran president
of all these MS-13 gangsters just being
hauled around this giant prison like
insects looking so weak so humiliated
then there was a an answer video to that
the kind of complementary video to that
was the president addressing the Army
troops who have rounded up all these
gangsters and it was bright and it was
inspiring and he was talking about God
and it was great now we've got another
propaganda video
it's a propaganda video of the president
sending these gangster prisoners To Go
destroy tombstones that have MS-13
symbols on them
I love this video you see their Ms right
there on a tombstone and you'll see too
the symbolism of Santa Muerte all this
occult demonic downright satanic
symbolism which has always been
associated with MS-13 MS-13 has a deeply
satanic element to it and so what does
the president do he not only destroys
their monuments these occult criminal
gangster
satanic monuments
he has the gangsters do it themselves he
forces them to do this
is this authoritarian
a gas as I've said before I don't really
know what that word means as far as I
can tell the word authoritarian is just
the word to describe one's political
opponents whenever whenever we do
something in politics that's good that's
wonderful that's that's very liberal
that's great but when our opponents do
something in politics that's always
authoritarian so sure call it
authoritarian this is my kind of
authority baby because the president in
El Salvador is the legitimate civil
Authority
he inherited this massive problem where
there was a rival power the Rival power
to the duly elected government is the
gangsters these these absolute Devils
who rape kill pillage and burn and so
what does the president do he says we're
gonna get rid of their power and not
only are we going to round them up and
not only are we going to cut off their
Commerce we're going to humiliate them
and we're going to destroy their symbols
and their gravestones we're going to
desecrate everything about these people
because there's nothing sacred about
what they're doing
everything they do is sacrilegious in
fact
really important
and the squishes don't quite get this
the squishes are the kinds who will say
oh who cares
whether you call a man he or she who
cares let's talk about something
important like taxes come on let's talk
about something that really matters like
the deficit or whatever
who cares if we call a man he or she
well
the libs care that's why they spend so
much time focusing on it
and they care because symbols matter
symbols
might be the most important thing in
politics these symbols are how we
communicate with one another symbols are
what binds a community together
if someone comes in and controls all the
symbols
changes all the symbols to to
better job with their political program
then they're going to control the
political order
so if Kelly knows it's not enough
to just round up the physical criminals
you've got to change the symbols too and
that that changes the meaning of our
political communities the rest of the
show continues now you don't want to
miss it become a member and use code
Knowles can a wlas a checkout for two
months free on all annual plans
[Music]
foreign